foreign
[Music]
hey guys what's up welcome to this show
congratulations
[Music]
I have a special announcement I have a
special announcement for all of you
that want to come sit in the Tall Grass
April 1st in Minneapolis crystalia.com I
will be filming my fifth special I will
be doing it in Minneapolis
uh my next special is announced and that
is when I will be doing it April 1st the
first show is already sold out the
second show uh there are tickets left
and they will sell out this is my
special that I am shooting
um and that is what's happening so
there's my special announcement I will
also be in uh Austin
yeah uh uh no uh November I mean not
even close to November uh March 25th and
I will be in uh different places Kansas
City and Tulsa uh Springfield so go to
chrisley.com and check it out uh where I
will be uh on the Don't Push Me Tour I
gotta say man it's been really really
great Chicago was awesome New York was
awesome I'll be in Midland Texas I
always forget that one because what is
it um it's from where it's where Woody
Harrelson was born
um
Columbus Ohio Cincinnati Woody Harrelson
was born in Midland Texas the only
reason why I know that is because my
wife was watching a documentary about
serial killers and the guy on it sounded
like
[__]
what's his name uh Woody Harrelson so
just like um and he was from South
Carolina and I thought I bet Woody
Harrelson is from South Carolina because
it sounds just like him I looked up
where videos from Midland Texas
dead wrong
um but it's all good the south is the
South and although it's not all the same
you got that draw you know what I mean
and that's me boy ding that's me boy
um
and uh I am very excited to be shooting
my special I want to do it uh I I you
know it's it's It's tricky because I'm
gonna do it now and then I guess I'll
probably release it a few months after
that I already have tour dates lined up
for the fall of this year they're not
out yet not sure when I'm gonna be
releasing them or uh announcing them but
uh I will be the Don't Push Me Tour but
I don't know when I'm gonna release this
especially when I release a special I
want the Don't Push Me Tour to be kind
of not over but I want to have new
materials so I got to incorporate some
new material on the dopest Resort so
we'll see what it is dude but um you
know the link below is where you get
tickets to this special uh where are the
special taping I was in New York I was
in Rhode Island first of all played the
Vets which was awesome uh haven't been
to Rhode Island before don't know why
it's not memorable but boy was it this
time
um
and uh yeah so I was in Rhode Island and
it was very fun then I went to New York
starts where I actually started
Spreading the News and dude it was so
cute because I was taking I took Calvin
and my wife
and Calvin kept on saying we're going to
New York to visit pop pop and we went to
pop-up is what he calls Grandpa you know
my my dad and uh
so he we went to New York and we saw pop
and it was absolutely beautiful because
February 18th was my show in New York
and February 18th was my my uh son's
birthday he turned three and February
18th my dad came to the show and it was
very sweet every time I'd look my dad is
the most sentimental person in the world
so
like honestly he CR I mean he he just
it's where I get my sentiment from
my babies it's working my sentiment from
but uh
and uh my sentimentality I guess is what
we call it not my sentiment I don't know
I'm dumb but um but he is
basically the most sentimental person in
the world and he
um came to the show did 20 people in my
family come to the show as well yes did
they all ask for tickets yes is that
thousand dollars out of my pocket yes is
it okay no but did we do it anyway yes
why because if I did my dad would be mad
and I'm Italian you know dude my dad is
so
my dad will be like
you drove by you drove by La Canada
and and you didn't say hi to your mother
and I'm just like Dad I was on the two
freeway you know you didn't exit
you didn't exit Hillard and drive up
and visit your mom for an hour and a
half your mother's pissed well why isn't
she calling me I gotta you know if my
mom's pissed the way I know my mom's
pissed is if my dad calls me that's how
I know if my mom's pissed I know if my
dad's pissed my dad's calls me if my
mom's pissed my dad calls me now that's
the Italian way that's the New Jersey
way and you know so that's what we do so
you didn't you didn't uh
you didn't visit your mother no no I
didn't but I were you were you on a 210
at all yeah
you didn't visit your mother
well but I was in the 210 it was really
far I was in Pasadena that's not an
excuse that's 12 minutes away
but then if I drive 12 minutes I drive
towards back then it's 24 minutes I stay
there for an hour it's like oh
you don't love your mother
she birthed you my dad doesn't sound
like that but it's still funny to make
him sound like that and so uh
my dad's so sentimental that uh I
believed in Santa Claus for way way too
late and that was part of me being like
[__] this [__] I'm gonna believe in
Santa Claus as much as I want to dude
kids in the school were telling me you
know he's not real and I was like nah
he's real
I don't care I don't even care if he's
not real I do I'm talking well into like
I mean
13 yeah
you figure out there's no Santa when
you're six
bro I was 13 like maybe not the 12
reindeers but someone's Santa
he probably has a reindeer or two they
don't fly I get it but you know what I
mean like like I was living in my uh
like if Santa like if like like uh
Christopher Nolan directed a Santa Claus
movie where it's like well the reindeers
don't fly but he is a real person he's
got guns
um we don't live in the North Pole lives
in Alaska you know
uh so
so yeah and then my mom said to me uh
when I was 11 you know there's no
there's no Santa Claus right I mean
let's I mean there there maybe is a
Santa Claus but Mom and Dad are the ones
that put the president under the tree
and I remember I was at my desk in New
Jersey and I was doing my homework and I
was yeah yeah yeah yeah I know and I
just knew the next time I talked to my
mom that she got in trouble for my dad
because my dad was like you're gonna
you're gonna tell him there's no Santa
Claus like he's only 11. like I was so
old at that point I had armpit hair
and um then the next uh Christmas we're
in La I must have been 12 or 13. I can't
remember and uh when when when I knew
there was no Santa Claus and then by the
way if you're sorry for spoiling it but
if you're in the cult here you know that
for sure there's no Santa Claus because
you got to be old enough to get in the
cult right so
and we got to sit in the high your Tall
Grass we're gonna start Christmas but ah
oh my son's crying here
is he all right
he's all right
um maybe my wife just told him there's
no Santa so uh so the next Christmas I
went down and there were things in the
down under the tree that I wanted that I
didn't necessarily say I wanted and my
dad's like hey look and I said yeah he
said look at that there Santa brought
that did you want that I said yeah he
said did you let Santa know did you tell
anybody that you wanted that I said no
he said oh so there must be a Santa huh
and he's like trying to backtrack I'm
like the damage is already done you
can't you know the the milk spilled
already you can't put it back in the
bottle so
um
anyway uh
uh my dad sentimental is [__] so I
here's how sentimental my dad is he goes
to my grandfather had ah dude
my grandfather had a news stand on 33rd
and 7th
and in New York and that's how we made
his money they were growing up they were
poor you know speaking of Christmas one
Christmas they had had gifts and they
had to return on the next day really sad
but um
so the uh
we went to uh so my dad every time he's
in New York he goes to 33rd and seventh
to feel his debt which is absolutely
[__] adorable dude my dad's cute as
[__] man what do you think I get it from
so he does that and one time there was a
billboard of me while he was standing
there uh where his newsstand used to be
and my dad just water works
what a moment right what a moment it's
great cool I don't remember what the
billboard was for you is there for a
dumb show I was on or when I was a model
for Hugo Boss but um
just like this
Aqua Di Giorgio just like this
coming out of a pool like this
um just Cascade just water just
cascading over the and so
um
so uh I I know he does that and I was
texting him this time he was in New York
he was there and I had my shows at the
Beacon Theater two of them he came to
see someone but not for too long because
he stand up at the end and so
um I did the show it's Calvin's birthday
at the end I said to my dad hey Calvin I
think wants to come out on the stage
with you do you want to do that he said
of course I'll do anything Calvin wants
didn't even ask Kevin about it just know
my dad would do it if Kevin would want
to do it I did what Hollywood Asians do
I was like yeah he he he wants to do it
so you should want to do it they go all
right and all of a sudden you you got
[__] Mark Wahlberg and Jeremy Renner
in a project where they both thought
they wanted to do it but really it was
they would only do it if each other did
it and there was no checking involved
and now they both said yes because they
thought and now you got a blockbuster
hit right
so
um so I get uh so I'm on stage I said
good night everybody and then it come
they come out
with balloons my dad brought the
balloons with Calvin because his
birthday and it was so sweet I'm hugging
my dad and I'm holding Calvin and then
um
and then you know
I say I I we leave and I don't know I on
the stage I'm like yeah my this is crazy
it's three generations of Delia and my
grandfather's not with us anymore but
it's all on the tour report that I put
up on my channel but um but I was like
uh you
um my grandfather would think this is a
trip you know I used to sell newspapers
whatever I'd say all that stuff then the
next day I go and I get I know I meet my
dad for dinner the next day so I go get
a tattoo at this place bang bang in New
York City and uh it's the the you can
see it right here but the street sign
West 33rd and 7th and 7th Avenue dude
not only am I sentimental I'm shoot as
[__]
isn't that sweet so now I'm yet it up
I'm crazy at it up and yeah it's you
know it's absolutely sexy but also it's
very sentimental right
yeah yeah yeah I gotta pass out towels
because you know I'm like like dude you
think I got more tattoos but you don't
even know about I got some that are half
done I haven't even exposed to you yet
so yeah I'm gonna have to get a bunch of
I gotta get Ikea bags of towels I gotta
dull them out because women are going to
be falling down breaking their [__]
necks when you see the kid you add it up
like this right okay sorry I need to get
insurance and towels okay so there's
that but also oh
he gets ones that mean stuff
so I showed it to my dad at dinner and
he teared up dude my dad's so
sentimental and that's where I get it
from man so sentimental
that's it once I let the walls down and
did too much therapy now he cries a lot
too yeah his brother talked about him I
bet he never talks about his feelings
yeah and he said yeah you're right but
then one who said because they
particularly knows this right yeah
yeah and then my brother decided the
only time I ever had a real conversation
with my mom was after two and a half
years ago in all chef and yeah
and I thought I did but I really didn't
but that's me being delusional and
compartmentalizing yeah
okay but it's all good dude so now he
gets tattoos that means something
that's why I said grow or die you know
what I mean
um
so yeah we did that and we did the uh
the New York show then we went to we
stayed in New York City and my my
[__] do it first of all it was
so cool seeing Kevin walk around the
city like city boy dude it was so cute
man I'm not gonna talk about my son the
whole time look I get it I'm a first
time Dad and sometimes people are like
bro does this guy like he's got a kid so
what dude how about this
my heart explodes for him so I'm not
going to talk about it too much but it's
just you know my family and just the
warmth and the you know the niceness and
dude [__] you for being shitty about
what I love how about that don't listen
dude as a matter of fact I want to
whittle down my fans and to really
really drive home the point that if
you're listening to this podcast or
watching this podcast you're a hardcore
[__] dude I don't want passive
listeners like huh I want [__]
that are sitting Indian style on the
grass helping to build this Log Cabin so
anyway dude I digress but
uh
uh yeah did the Chicago Theater I guess
I'm going back to the Chicago Theater
later on this year because it was just
so freaking great
so what do we talk about dude
that was just me catching up to catching
you guys up to what's been going on in
my life because dude I haven't been
doing the podcast for 10 10 days
I was in New York City do it and I went
to get a car by the way this coffee shop
is really good I forget what it's called
um but I went in to get the coffee shop
to get the coffee to get my four shots
over ice first of all I need to get four
stars over the ice
winning with Danny love the guy who
opens for me comedian he's really great
um
and he was like they he asked them for
for he was like
dude he wants coffee he doesn't know
coffee but he's like I'm trying to get
into coffee and he'll go and he'll get
like the [__] red frilly drink like
the strawberry supreme or whatever but
like the coffee version I'm so not not
strawberry but like the vanilla [__]
and also mocha ends with syrup in it and
also pancakes coffee the latte right and
he'll be drinking it'll be like he'll be
drinking it and there's like a like
there's literally like like a cinnamon
stick coming out of it and some plants
and dominoes you know like just so like
just full of [__] and he'll drink it and
be like I'm not and so every time I see
it I'm always like oh dude you're
meeting up with a chick I go like that
and we have a laugh you know I say oh
dude who's the girl you're meeting up
with like you know what I mean
so uh so we go in there and he's like
could I get it with vanilla and they
were like we don't have flavor dude just
straight up the coffee shop that just
goes like this we don't have flavor
like the most [__] my when when I
say it's my dream to open up a shop
where you that where you taste stuff and
then you got the balls to be like we
don't have flavor
is the most unbelievable [__] that's so
gangster oh you came here for Taste and
stuff great this is gonna be overpriced
by the way don't ask for flavor cause we
got none
so then I get my four shots over ice but
I go like this now this is this is how
hardcore of a coffee drinker I am we're
at a hardcore coffee place so hardcore
doesn't have flavor I asked for four
shots over ice and the lady says you
want one shot and I say no no no and she
says do you want two double I said no no
four and she says
do you wanna die
that's dude she says
you want to die and now I'm realizing
when I say that she said that because of
how strong their coffee is because they
were like a hardcore Place With No
flavor and I drank it was very strong
now that I think about it but yeah I
drank that [__] still alive
but bro it was so funny man you wanna
die the best place I've ever been to I
can't even remember what it's called
I'll flash it on the screen because I'll
remember later and I'll have uh I even
get rid of put it up there
congratulations for that
um
but yeah
I got this new tattoo and it's [__]
cool man it's appealing right now
I went to this place in Chicago called
elski it's a restaurant and we went
because it's a Michelin star restaurant
and I didn't know about this but like
there's like how many people how many
places in America that have like a
three-star Michelin like not that many
and then there's two and then there's
one and like a city like Chicago has
like 31 stars like it's not many you
know
maybe not even 30 maybe like 20. and
Krista was like let's go to this place
so I was like all right cool so we go
the the [__]
like
the absolute
balls that you talk about like hardcore
copy the blows these place these places
have
honestly every
one or two star at least two or or
three star restaurants Michelin star
restaurants
should only legally be able to be called
balls
they should be called balls restaurant
or my big balls my big bald Cafe
because this [__] first of all they'll
do eight courses so
my balls are big that's basically what
they're saying he's like ah a course
dude here's how many courses a meal
should be
one
all right and you might be like what
about appetizer no you know what
appetizer for to wet the appetite for
the real meal nope just give me the real
meal
at best maybe dessert so maybe two but
one
okay
appetizer nope bring it with the meal on
the same plate make it one
okay
so we go to this place that has like 11
courses
and I'm like well these courses are
probably small so let me add
you could either get the set menu which
is go honestly
blow yourself
I get it I get it a chef is a an artist
and yeah yeah no substitutions and I get
it but also
name your place balls Cafe okay
so
so the first uh
uh uh what do you call it uh
of course
is is too little [__] ass
blocks like I'm talking that big of go
like it's like goat cheese and egg yolk
and like a crepey kind of thing on it
and I I I I actually you know what you
know what it is you know what they
brought out first I I don't know
cause it's balls Cafe
I mean you got the chef in there sitting
on them like like it's like at the toy
store when they're bouncing on the
[__] thing
you know what I'm talking about with the
handle and it look just he's like Randy
Marsh wagging in his balls hey what what
hey everybody did the lamb come in did
the rabbit ears come in
hey uh Chef balls
so so the and by the way two little
[__] ass things and dude they got a
plate this big the two [__] ass block
things are on the side of the plate dude
like hey you missed
they act like dude like well yo no go
negative SP take your negatives you know
what else there's negative spec up your
ass dude
hey dude you missed the place
first I guess guess how quickly I ate
the first course
0.001 seconds dude
and Kristen's laughing she's like man
you don't do mindful eatings which is
something that I did in rehab but then
dude people were like you got to do
mindful eating you got to really taste
the food I don't know why this is part
of the plan rehab but like you know
don't just eat the food so much product
because we're an addict and a lot of
food addicts there probably don't look
over eaters you know and don't forget
you know you gotta really taste the food
and put the fork down and think about it
and taste the food and I'm like dude
mindful eating [__] all this and people
were trying to do the mindful eating and
I I did it but I learned how to do it
real well so I just [__] did it
really quickly
I'm mindful eat it real quick
crazy crazy
hey guys I want to talk to you about
mood and listen whether you're new to
cannabis or an Old Pro there's no
denying that many of the products on the
market seem iffy honestly at best and
when you want to relax if fee is the
last thing you want to feel okay uh mood
puts an end to guessing games it's a
hundred percent federally legal Delta 8
and Delta 9 THC you can have shipped
straight to you no doctors no waiting
all right just Affordable Legal THC
um I gave it to my brother and uh one
fire and one fire swears by it he said
it helps with his stress and uh keeps
him calm and he actually sleeps easier I
just think that this is a a great
product because one thing's for sure one
fire ain't lion uh it's a really neat
way to shop for THC you shop by mood
like Focus euphoric or creative uh and
um it's priced great and uh one far use
the euphoric gummies and fruity crispy
treats and the THC moon rocks mood
offers federally legal forms of THC
extracted from hemp plants look man
great tasting gummies classic flower
convenient pre-rolls and so much more
um so if you like THC mood has you
covered great for both beginner and
Veteran users by the way ready for a
good time without the guesswork order
your THC products from mood today and
for 20 off your first order and free
gummies go to hellomood.com and use
promo code congrats that's specific to
my listeners so that's 20 off your first
order that is hello
m-o-o-d.com promo code congrats for 20
off your order and free gummies
crazy
[Music]
so anyway the second course comes man
what the [__] was it dude I took
pictures of all of them actually I'm
gonna I got I took pictures of all of
them
um
I took pictures of all of them and I'm
gonna go get them and you're gonna wait
here while I scroll through it because
dude I'm gonna describe these pictures
and I'm actually going to put them on
the thing I'm going to have Ivan get rid
of put them on the thing
um I don't know when this was let's see
so I'm going to be really respectful and
just scroll through my phone as you guys
are listening and you guys are going to
stay here okay because you're about it
because you're about it because honestly
about it now I was just looking through
videos so that pisses me off I was
looking at the videos uh because I I was
not even looking through pictures now
that makes me really mad but you know
what you stayed anyway do you know why
you bout it okay here it is found it it
was way quicker which isn't from the
videos first all right um so that was
the thing two [__] ass so here's what
the thing oh yeah oh two [__] ass
things and then two more [__] ass
things on the side of it on a different
plate that we're Center in the center of
the thing this is me being this is me
right in the menu so first course two
[__] ass things on the side of the
plate in parentheses sorry we missed the
plate and also two [__] ass things that
tasted like donuts but were really small
and should have been for dessert and
also a drink that we pretend is a meal
and it has
I don't even know what was in it a
tastes Smokey as [__] all right so that
was the first meal second meal was
they bring it's a bowl and the guy's
like so it's in bro and then you know
they'll do the whole thing where they
explain it they're just like so here we
have and I'm already done with the
course by the time it gets to the word
half
so here we have
um
so they're dumplings they're the chef's
uh take anytime a chef does a take you
know it's not the thing so it's the
chef's take on a dumpling and I'm
looking no dumpling there's pork inside
it didn't taste the pork flaps the
little like flap over it like little
beads of pork and in broth I guess but
it was more like froth
and they were like literally I asked the
guy do you eat it with a
fork or a spoon he's gonna eat it with
the spoon and I tried it with the spoon
and then it would have been working I
took it with the fork because dude they
tricked me there's no real broth
so it was like pork dumplings that
weren't pork dumplings so that was the
second meal
and the third meal the third course was
oh yeah
um
Sable fish
with
chamomile Flakes and shrimp under it now
that was banging look by the way it was
all very good I'm not
all very good but also more
okay I also because the the the the the
what do you call the courses we're gonna
be little I knew to order more so I also
ordered the halibut and also they're
called nudies which is like gnocchi
didn't know what it was but it tasted it
was so banging the nudie and the
whatever dude I'm a food critic but this
is
that place else you was great so then we
got to have didn't like the chamomile in
it in the [__] you know
then got the halibut and the nudie and
boy those were tens man just tens
God the hell a bit in the in the nudity
and then dude then it was the only
course I did not like
liver
pate and like dude they they brought it
in the shape of a pie
and it's like I thought it was dessert
and I ate it dude and I just not a liver
fan duck liver okay
you know it's like and it was in the
shape of a pie Ada I said where's the
utensils they say you eat it with your
hands I ate all my hands it was cold it
was disgusting not a fan of liver and
then it was duck breast or some [__] a
duck
it was all right
and then dude they gave us two charcoal
pieces to cleanse the palate before
dessert and then I ate it and I
pretended like it was dessert to Kristen
and she I was like man that's a crazy
dessert and she didn't listen because
she doesn't listen a lot sometimes and
then she was like I was like yeah that
was good and she's like oh that's
interesting and I was like ah your jokes
on you it was just a palette cleanser
then the real dessert came
and it was ice cream and it was good you
know but like dude
these places man oh and the bill was
550.
[Music]
oh so all good but
um just absolutely absolutely [__]
crazy
absolutely crazy I have to do this
but a good place
dude when you go to how about this man
people always talk about New York his
hot take New York
I haven't been in New York since before
the pandemic
don't like 80 of the restaurants now
close at like midnight it used to be 24
hours you got to like travel far
if you want to get some at 1am or 2 A.M
it sucks all right now I'm Mr New York
now I believe New York right now my soul
rests easy in New York right like when
I'm in L.A a piece of me is missing
and it's a piece of you know it's my my
soul is in New York right and we all
know that I am New York so
so
I
you can't get food late at night unless
you go far right unless you live next to
one of these spots now people are in the
comments crying you you did you should
have went they should have went to this
or that or the Stardust Diner whatever
the [__] you know all right so
how about this living in New York I
cannot imagine living in New York your
whole life that would suck donkey balls
now here's that's the hot take the hot
take and here's why people say la in
traffic is the worst thing in the world
dude
at least in La you have to drive to get
to the traffic
okay in La you're at least at your house
and then you drive a few blocks and then
you go ah [__] this LA traffic
in New York
you walk out your door and there's
traffic
already by the way on the sidewalk
you get your oh oh and you get to the
car baby you're sitting got this guy
pulling out
God damn [__] [__] god [__] ass [__]
God damn [__]
someone hits the roof and the other guy
hey they don't care no one cares let me
get shot you know
it's so annoying dude the traffic in New
York [__] sucks this is what you say
you're gonna be like yo um so uh how far
away is it and they this is always the
answer in New York it's only like six
blocks but it takes 25 minutes
really because of traffic yeah and also
you got to turn around and do the
[__] thing and it's a one-way Street
oh dude blow me New York it's not it
anymore you know what's it Brooklyn but
then you go to Brooklyn you see all the
people with the twisty mustaches you go
wipe my [__] dude get out of here man
no
so there's no place to live it's either
hipster City or traffic central and that
sucks
what about the regular day killer
I want to be regular regular you can't
New York City dude
so that's what's up man
so that's what's up and that sucks so la
you know I look I get it LA's well it's
uh you know
I guess I want to say la was great the
pandemic ruined everything man
which is why I want to you know we're
building a house now outside of the
[__] LA because I want some regular
daggler dude
the traffic in New York is way worse now
dude pretty soon New York's just going
to be a place where you go to they're oh
it's going to be everything in New York
is gonna be a either a hotel or a Dwayne
Reed
and maybe like there'll be some pizza
shops but it'll everything will be a
chain like nobody no who the [__] lives
in New York anymore
you're just [__] Dwayne read after
Dwayne Reed Starbucks after Dwayne Reed
and then like you can go see Aladdin and
the Lion King
I get it dude it's you know and there's
still those die hard yeah but nah you
just don't know where to go uh
well how about how five years ago you
just stepped outside and everything was
a [__] party
five years ago you could stay at 33rd
and [__] and walk out and still have
a great time
[__] beard is on there
and now dude everything is a Duane read
it just sucks
um
so yeah I don't know how about this
[__] [__] Tiger Woods
this is great first of all
love it Tiger Woods women's group rips
tampon gag misogynistic tone deaf
salaries this even
[__] news I mean it's not news but
it's news you know I mean it's not news
but
and uh
so he
this is so funny he did this by the way
now I'm a huge Tiger Woods fan I don't
care about golf but this guy
Tiger Woods is being called out by a
woman's Empowerment Group for his tampon
prank at a PGA Tour event saying how
dare he especially with a daughter at
home
the CEO of women's Global empowerment
fund tells TMZ tiger stand upon a moment
was not only misogynistic but also tone
deaf and straight up disrespectful to
women and girls all over the world
sugar ripped the golfing Legend So
here's what he did
he
won up to this golfer like this golfer
did a shot and he did a shot and it was
much better and then he walked over and
handed him a tampon dude which by the
way is so [__] funny because of how
just so frat guy and shitty it is you
know also Tiger Woods either two things
happened here Tiger Woods either went to
go get a tampon to do this
or got his assistant to pick up tampons
too
like that's unbelievable that's
unbelievable
that that he was like I'm gonna do this
and I'm gonna [__] do a crazy cool
shot which I do because I'm targeting
ones
I'm gonna go [__]
get him in the tampon so funny okay
and now this woman of the woman head of
the women's group
is saying how it's tone deaf
sugar ripped golfing Legend wondering if
he's intimidating periods oh intimating
periods are embarrassing or shameful or
a sign of weakness
okay so here's the deal
uh
uh men
are uh
uh more more uh manly I guess and what
is manly I guess so that doesn't make
sense you can't say matter here I go get
in trouble but
um
the the the the the the the
how do I not skate around this how do I
go right through the [__] bowling
pins but
um
Sports male Sports if you want to say
they're toxic fine
uh I don't like that word
there's a very if manly is a thing
then on manly is a thing and in sports
being manly is equated with being good
in men's sports
okay
so saying hey guy I know you value this
in yourself but check this out
you got a [__]
is a [__] funny thing to do right
and
if
having a look having a period isn't a
sign of weakness
but being weaker is a sign of weakness
and women genuinely when it comes to
physical strength generally
the weaker okay and that's okay you're
different you're better at other things
you're better at other things and that's
[__] awesome dude
but dude this is absolutely hilarious
that he did this
the women's group says it's sad to see
if I could do this because he's a grown
man with a daughter and they feel the
joke distraction the serious issues
involving mental health and period
mental health [__] mental health have
to do with this
which women girls are about to go
he gave an apology non-apology saying it
was supposed to be all fun and games
obviously hasn't turned out that way if
anyway nah don't say that if I offended
anybody anyway I'm sorry
yeah that's not a real apology but also
just don't do it
yeah women can speak and compete in
sports in all areas of life while
handling their periods so tampons are no
joke is what they wrote dude yeah women
can be in sports yeah yeah not with guys
because they're not as good dude
they're not you're not gonna see [__]
even Brittany Greiner who's like will
sell out she's not gonna be sitting
there with LeBron dude
I don't know it's not it's like dude
oh so insane though like the Dilbert guy
how about how the Dilbert guy just goes
I'm cashing in
ah you know what
[__] it
I'm cashing in to make I accept like 70
million dollars he's been drawing this
dog [__] cartoon since 1980 you know and
I'm not I'm not look dude
speak your mind free your [__] mind
the cartoon Dilbert stock [__]
okay it's all good do what you do make
that stack those racks
fine
stock [__] okay bilbert will walk in and
be like where's my brain and the guy's
like and then Double's like and it's on
a hundred newspapers across the world
dog [__] okay it's fine but Dilbert your
whole life's Works dog [__] and it's
fine and I don't care and I like when
someone frees their mind and speaks
their mind now we are not racist here at
the congratulations studios Okay at the
super good Studios we're not racist but
this Dilbert guy dude I actually want to
play the [__] video because holy
[__] dude the guy
the guy just doubled down he goes
Dilbert here let me
you looking for headphones yeah they're
in my backpack dude sorry I took them
um now of course we're gonna get through
all the Shins
[Music]
you don't have another pair there
yeah
here let me play some of this dude this
is so ridiculous how he did it
also it looks like Cal Ripken Jr
Cal races Junior
come on let's play it here we go and
it's in dude you heard about this right
you know about this right yeah
dude so if if you know nearly half of
all blacks are not okay with white
people according to this poll he put out
a poll in Twitter where he was like
where he was like wow he's got this
Spider-Man uh
headphones like from because there's a
Calvin's I don't even fit his head
he's gonna have to listen in one ear
um so
he basically put out a poll is it oh is
it okay to be white or not and 53 of the
people I said like yeah it's okay to be
white which means there were like 40
some people that says yeah it's not okay
to be right and he was saying that it's
racist now is that racist
okay now do I want to die on that Hill
who cares doesn't matter but my point is
if you do adoption cartoon in 100
Publications Across America can't be
saying stuff like that all right so he
did it he tweeted that obviously he
wanted to be incendiary guys we're 70
mil
all right so the guy wants to cash out
so
then he put he puts this video up so if
if you know nearly half of All Blacks
first of all calling them blacks whoa
are not okay with white people according
to this poll not according to me
according to this poll
that's a hate group
this man just said blacks
all right
all right hate group
not he didn't even say some blacks which
which would still be like whoa buddy the
guy just goes blacks
are are a hate crew
huh
that's the [__] Awards
that's a hate group that's double
downtown I won't have anything to do
with them
um
I don't have anything to do with uh
meaning blacks
and I would say you know based on the
current way things work it can't get
much worse that's the advice I would
give to at least people can't get much
worse is to get the hell away from black
people
the fact that not only he said white
people should get away from black people
but the fact that he said white people
should get the hell away from black
people is like you feel the vitriol
under his speaking right
uh uh why people and the fact that he's
doing this the whole time uh white
people should uh get the hell away from
black people
just get the [__] away
wherever you have to go just get away
like like they're everywhere you know
where we have to go just like you're
just in
well this is better than being around
them blacks in the in the in the
Atlantic in the Potomac
you know they don't swim so
scared of water just racist
[__] out there
so that is uh Scott Adams dude
it's so funny that a cartoonist can even
be racist you know
I draw
so everybody was just like done done
with them and I'm just like wow and I
looked in the comments and dude some
people are just all for it
it's crazy how like
my favorite are the black dudes that are
come out and are like yeah it's up to
our kind to do better and we don't know
God damn dude
what did Ben Stiller do
one fire sent me this
oh
did these are getting canceled or no no
he said I make no apologies for Tropic
Thunder oh wait somebody said
what is this so Benny s
wrote to Ben Stiller please stop
apologizing for doing this movie it
wasn't still as funny as [__] even
funnier now with cancer culture that the
way it is it's a movie y'all can just
get over it
I was dying level when I saw first back
in the day and so is everyone else
I noticed how in Twitter however okay
yeah yeah and then the guy says I
noticed how Twitter I notice my Twitter
how liberals have been trying to cancel
call to the movie Tropic Thunder now
people like Ben Stiller are actually
apologizing for what it's a classic
movie funny as [__]
if you haven't seen it it's a satirical
movie
he does it in blackface whatever well
his whole body's black whatever
stop a positive for this stuff and then
Ben Stiller writes I make no apologies
for Tropic Thunder don't know who told
you that it's always been a
controversial movie since we opened this
is when we open proud of it and the work
everyone did on it nice
um
[Music]
I guess this is a tweet he did
actually Tropic Thunder was booked out
of 10 years ago when it came out and I
apologize then it was always meant to
make fun of actors trying to do anything
to win Awards yeah of course I stand my
biomology in the movie I stand by my
apology in the movie Sean White
and the great people that work in there
oh so he did apologize for it then
why is Sean White
hmm
that was 2018.
yeah dude it's it's it's it's like
that's the thing about this is that they
don't
even go to the fact that they're making
fun of a guy who would do this but
whatever hey nobody gives a [__]
um
how about this Andrew Tate tweet
sup
what does he mean sup
he writes
I was awoken last night by an icy chill
poetry and then he writes and identified
a ghost in my prison cell oops you had
it for a minute there
dude Andrew Tate that's the thing man
once you reach escape velocity you can
say anything
and people were just like okay there
were ghosts then I believe you I've
invested too much of myself to follow
you
I was working last night by an icy chill
and identified a ghost in my prison cell
he was terrified and begged me not to
annihilate him
the most [__] wow dude to have it
like that
to have it like that why would go hey
dude first of all I'm finding flaws in
this tweet why is the ghost even showing
up
be it another area
at least be an interesting kitchen where
he's not sleeping
oh he's in he's in jail yeah and just
tell uh he was terrified and beg me not
denial him I sent him back to hell with
a message for the demons I am always
ready
whoa dude
look this guy writes gotta respect a man
that never stops growing
Andrew take social media phenomenon
kickboxing champion internet pimp
business coach
and Ghostbuster
that's cool dude
free your mind dude
free your [__] mind
Andrew Tate free Andrew Tate right isn't
that what they say I have no idea
they're they're Sure Shot of betting
this video but I'm saying Andrew Tate
too much
um
yeah he DM me a long time ago uh and was
talking about
uh
how everyone was mad at him
and we were having a laugh
and that's it
he said let me come on your podcast and
I was like
um
he did he said let me come on your
podcast let me know when you want to do
the best podcast of all time
and I wrote uh okay but I don't have
guests on my podcast
and uh that's that it was a while ago
so how's that for how's that for some
Insider Biz dude how's that for some BTS
I guess Tommy Fury beat Jake Paul in
decision all right I guess it was a
split decision every time I hear Split
Decision I think of Ace Ventura saying
quick decision and then throwing her
into the
water
um
wow that's so funny quick decision like
so dumb and funny wow Jim Carrey's
awesome so
um yeah you beat him I like you know
what I like about Jake Paul dude he'll
talk so much [__] and then afterwards
he'll be like fair play dude you won
congrats to you and your family that's
so [__] awesome that means he's
playing a game of boxing and he's doing
it well did the guys in marketing genius
right
and so am I
so we have something in common
um
what else did I do this week I [__] I
did a um
I'm [__] tired man
I may need more of that coffee where she
said you want to die
shout out to my friggin
homies
um
let's look at some of these here I like
doing these let's do look at some of
these um what do you call it
uh
GPT chat GPT crystallia jokes this is a
new section we do here on the show chat
GPT crystallia jokes on caviar
hey what's the deal with caviar it's
like let me get this straight we're
paying top dollar for fish eggs I mean
come on people if we really wanted to
eat fish eggs we could just go fishing
and squeeze them out ourselves so not a
joke also something I would say because
I don't do jokes
um I mean come on people to sew
something I've never said
I mean come on people I've literally
never said that my life except for Chad
gbd
uh
reciting chat GPT jokes here's one on
cruise ships
well this is actually a hilarious line
hey you ever been on a cruise it's like
a floating hotel but with a lot more
diarrhea
I mean you're basically trapped on a
boat with a bunch of strangers all
trying to avoid the same overcooked
buffet food I mean the first sign of
that is hilarious
oh crush on stage gonna do it
and let's not forget about the
entertainment there's always some cheesy
magician or washed up comedian me nah I
didn't say that part I'm trying to make
you laugh yeah good luck with that buddy
I'm too busy trying not to get seasick
wow so bad but you know what the best
part of the cruise is get off the damn
thing I mean you've been stuck in a boat
for a week you only kiss the ground when
you finally dock so yeah you want to
spend your time vacation feeling like
you're on a floating petri dish go ahead
and book that cruise no so bad first
line was funny
here's Burger King Chad GPD jokes
Chrisley
Burger King huh well I like that already
Burger King huh more like Burger Prince
am I right did I do this already they're
all the same you just did this now
wow Burger
am I right
I mean who are they trying to fool with
that crown logo I didn't do this already
did you do it
wow
did I even get rid of do the same thing
no maybe not but it just feels so am I
having a [__] what do you call it
deja vu
yeah no I didn't do this but no amount
of slow motion shots is gonna make me
forget that time I've got food poisoning
from your Whopper hey guess if you're
gonna guess if you're into hey I guess
if you're in a soggy buns and wilted
lettuce Burger King is the ways for you
just make sure to bring your own Crown
because you definitely won't be feeling
like a king after eating their wow so
bad dude you would that would so be a
joke that somebody would do in an open
mic in a hostel
um
wow
oh man guess what joke's on you guys
I've been nauseous the whole time I've
been doing this this um
podcast and it's been okay
so
[Music]
still did it got through it three times
didn't work yes dude awesome times
didn't work yes dude
absolutely freaking awesome but uh
congratulations today brought to you by
me
brought to you by me so like And
subscribe to [__] my other channel has
been [__] pumping though and getting
followers got like 30 000 followers in
the past few days uh Crystal Lee Channel
that's what's up dude
uh let's do some Tinder some some
dessert let's do some tender nah let's
do some Tinder or deserved scale
let's do some deserved scale here we go
I was trying to jump over the leak pipe
with tremendous water pressure well we
know how that ends up
who's a woman or man
oh
I mean oh my god dude first of all
bitched out completely because it only
kind of put the side of his leg over it
and still flipped all the way around
dude that's unbelievable
oh my God broke his [__] neck
wow somebody wrote public enema number
one that's pretty funny
uh that is just so bad you could die
like that
so
that's an eight because it was very
funny but also you can die like that so
let's not let's not have that happen
anymore huh
here's another one running and flipping
oh the music is so bad
so running oh
running and flipping off is what it is
you gave the guy their finger and then
ate [__]
oh this is a bus oh hit a pole oof
oh
oh the guy behind him is doing a Naruto
run Naruto run literally wow those guys
are all darks everything's everybody's
such a dork in there
um
yeah that's a N8 as well but there was
some pain in that so I feel bad about
that oh if you ever hit that [__] that
happened to me once not running but
walking it hurts so bad walking it hurts
so bad I must passed out so running I
can't even [__] imagine
oh there's another one here you put
the [__]
driving a bike off a ramp into water
oh
have we not seen this one dude there's
so many videos like this I can't even
I'm having Deja Vu create it's crazy oh
flipped around hit the water I hope they
didn't die okay that is an eight eight
where there's land of the eights because
this is not so funny man
I like when they go like no no no no no
no or like whoa whoa whoa or like
they're like now watch it and then
that's the end of the show for YouTube
if you want to catch the uncut episode
the uh with no ads uh and uh the raw
uncut episode go to uh patreon.com
crystalia and uh you can all get that
and for six bucks and also you can get
the rest of the episodes we've done like
24 every month there's a episode for
patreon you can go get them if you go
subscribe to the patreon for six bucks
patreon.com Chrisley thanks very much
guys
[Music]
thank you